- So, I hate to tell you this,
but it seems like the Trump Campaign
might not have been on the level.
Thousands are claiming
that they were scammed
out of millions of dollars
because they went to donate
to the Trump Campaign,
but instead of the Trump Campaign
taking only one donation,
it actually took a series
of recurring donations.
And looking at the language,
you can see why someone would be confused
that if you didn't uncheck a
box that was already checked,
it would lead to more recurring
or at least multiple donations.
And the part that says
that there is a recurring
transaction is actually smaller
than the rest of the text.
Many are claiming that this
is an unfair business practice
and that they were scamming
people out of money.
And it's no surprise that many thousands
of people were able to get refunds
as a result of these practices.
We'll see if this leads to
more inquiries than just that.
And we'll see you in court.